the bad news for Donald Trump he
probably will not get more votes than
Hillary Clinton
the good news Reid Ahnold Trump and the
political equivalent of the walking dead
that now surrounds him he certainly will
get more votes than Bill Clinton those
zombies around Trump have crashed
whatever campaign he actually had and
are this close to taking the entire
Republican Party with them because while
certainly they want to defeat Hillary
re-litigating the Bill Clinton
presidency for the 4,000 time and
beating her up and beating him up
he's almost dissatisfied and Trump who
by this point barely has any idea where
he is or what month this is or when the
election day is has been subsumed by
what we once called the vast right-wing
conspiracy the woman from Connecticut
let out a snort and a guttural laugh
vast she said to me on the afternoon of
Sunday March 15th 1998 there's like a
dozen of us I'll explain it to you later
it was just 47 days since the phrase had
been introduced to the public parlance a
few days into the Monica Lewinsky
scandal Hillary Clinton herself told The
Today Show
I mean look at the very people who are
involved in this they have popped up in
other settings this is the great story
here for anybody willing to find it and
write about it and explain it is this
vast right-wing conspiracy that has been
conspiring against my husband since the
day he announced for president and thus
was the term the vast right-wing
conspiracy borne well not really it
appeared in the Detroit News as early as
1991 and here sadly after the bombing of
the Murrah Building in Oklahoma City in
1995 Republicans mocked the 1998 phrase
immediately but the Republican I was
with never question that Hillary Clinton
had the idea right only that she had
gotten the vast part wrong vast she said
again after serving me a steak the size
of a dinosaur and after we watched with
the pretty much equal boredom and over
hyped interview on 60 minutes with
another Bill Clinton accuser named
Kathleen Willey
let me show you how this works we went
upstairs to her office she pointed to
her fax machine there there is the vast
nerve center of the vast right-wing
conspiracy the woman from Connecticut
said she would get
incoming faxes on that machine from any
one of a handful of people make sure
then that she cut off anything that
identified the fax machine from which
the fax was sent and then simply fax it
back out to her own brother who would
literally hand it to his friend Drudge
she called him Matt Drudge the faxes
would contain gossip about the Clintons
or tidbits from investigations that had
gone nowhere or anything else that might
hurt or just waste the time of the White
House their sources were few she
mentioned a woman called Kelli Ann whose
name I thought I recognized there was
also a guy an investigator in Congress
and Dan Burton's office named Bosh or
Bosley or something there were also a
couple of minor folks inside ken starr's
office and she also mentioned a senator
well I wasn't sure then I'm not sure now
if she meant him or did somebody who
worked for him they sent him to me I
figure out how we could do the most
damage with him I faxed him to my
brother he gives them to his pal Drudge
the woman from Connecticut now turned
slightly and looked seductively at me
out of the corners of her eyes of course
I could send them to you why you stop
and probably come to the same conclusion
that I did right at that moment then
that I was not just being shown the not
so vast right-wing conspiracy I was
being recruited offered the most public
position in it
I should explain the context I was then
hosting a news hour on MSNBC which had
not even two months earlier gone from
complete obscurity to market dominance
because we went all the Winsky and at
that point I had been so neutral in my
coverage that no less a partisan figure
than Mary Madeline had asked me on her
radio show if I was a conservative or a
liberal since she couldn't tell with the
woman from Connecticut doing the pitch
they wanted me to be the TV version of
Drudge taking out these washed
exaggerated sometimes interesting
sometimes even true dings against the
Clintons and offered them up as news
scoops to my suddenly huge TV audience
the woman from Connecticut of course was
named Laura Ingraham and from long
before this she was part of this
unfortunate image at the Republican
convention in Cleveland
she had been pushing Donald Trump and
she is behind him and advising him still
we were on a date Laura was and is a
bright and charming woman and actually
very sweet except for the you know
instantaneous blind anger part that
follows the mention of the name Clinton
the date was more than just steak and TV
and fax machines we had spent the
afternoon at the Supreme Court where she
had clerked for Clarence Thomas she got
me inside the chamber had me sit in his
chair Justice Thomas wasn't there so it
was exactly the same as if he had been
there the others well Drudge you know
that Kellyanne was Kelly Ann Fitzpatrick
and why I had recognized her name was
she was a ubiquitous presence on the
burgeoning anti-clinton TV show market
she later married one of the lawyers who
worked on the paula jones lawsuit his
name was Conway
she's now Kelly Anne Conway and yes
she's Trump's campaign manager or at
least she was when he recorded this so
you should check the internet to make
sure it's still true the investigator in
congressman Burton's office Bausch
Bosley whatever that was David bossy he
would be forced out shortly thereafter
following an accusation of doctoring
evidence against the Clintons I mean
doctoring it too much even for the
Republicans then he ran a little group
called citizens united and helped to
ruin America and now David bossy is
Trump's deputy campaign manager so there
are two things to understand when
Hillary Clinton said there was a vast
right-wing conspiracy to undermine her
husband she was wrong it wasn't vast but
it sure had stamina even as its public
faces like Newt Gingrich committed
career suicide tried to lay the Clintons
low it stayed alive often underground
until the opportunity arose her comeback
you know like Dracula and that's the
second thing to understand that
opportunity was Donald Trump he probably
doesn't even realize it but now you do
and in this part of this nightmare
journey Trump is actually something of a
victim
sure Ingram and Conway and bossy and
Drudge and the others would like to see
him elected but if he crashes and burns
and ruins
businesses has to leave the country in
disgrace and goes into the history books
as the man who tried to replace the
government of the United States with a
dictatorship with a bad comb-over hey at
least they scuffed Hillary up again and
a president hillary means they can get
the band back together and spend the
next four years conspiring against her
they got what they wanted
that's the closer i'm keith olbermann
watch this space